- So, how do you come up with your tricks?
How do you do that?
- I listen to the secret invisible fairies
that float around my head.
(Kelly laughing)
- Here in me head, all of them.
- You know, anything can be,
a lot of coffee.
Oh, this is...
- Is that coffee? Yes.
- No, that's so funny a minute
ago in the dressing room.
- Oh, there you go, we got you sugar.
- Thank you.
Oh, I was like, I wanted coffee.
- You're welcome.
- I didn't need it for out here-
- We aim to please at
the Kelly Clarkson show.
- but now that I have it.
- Yeah, I have...
- Coffee does help.
- [Kelly] I have tea, there you go.
- You guys are wine,
is that wine in there?
- No, I have, or I had wine.
Oh damn, they took it.
(laughter)
So quick.
It's like, they're like,
she's got a problem,
take the wine away.
- I used to drink, you drink coffee?
- I do.
- Do you drink a black?
- I drink it in many ways.
- [Michael] Oh.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- Depending on what mood I'm in.
- I drink, I drink with
reconstituted sugar.
- Oh.
- What the hell does that mean?
- Well, this is this is just
regular sugar, but I, I...
- [Kelly] What's reconstituted,
what does that mean?
I don't know what that means.
- Oh, you don't know reconstituted
sugar. It takes out...
- You know what that means?
I don't know what that means.
It takes out the, the
calories from the sugar.
- You know, that's why I
don't know what this means.
(audience laughing)
- I'm gonna teach you how
to reconstitute sugar.
- I don't, I don't reconstitute much,
- I do, I do hands.
- My friend.
- I, I hand reconstitute the sugar.
- Okay, wait, what?
- Pour the sugar.
- Oh, okay.
- Into your hand.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You could buy it reconstituted already.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But having it, if you
just do it in your hand
like that and it's a reconstitute,
and then you kind of just hold
it up in the air like that.
So you can see, you can see it.
Look, look, look, look.
There's like little pieces
of it right there floating right there.
- [Kelly] No, there's not, it's gone.
- Catch it and then when it
reconstitutes it comes back
and it doesn't have...
- What the hell!
- Doesn't have the calories anymore.
- What?!
- So.
(audience applauding)
- Did you see it, did
you see what happened?
- No, he had nothing in his hands.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I didn't even know...
- Still tastes as good.
- You were going into a magic trick.
I almost ruined your thing with my...
- That's the prank!
- I know, I'm so sorry.
I like totally pulled out
the Webster dictionary
and was like, what does that mean?
Like I'm, that is incredible.
- Thank you.
- Oh my God, you're so cool.
- You try it, you could try it.
- Totally.
I can make it disappear
just casue I eat it.
(audience chuckling)